-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
The 94th Academy Awards
were held last night
and featured
the first live performance
of "We don't Talk About Bruno"
from the Disney musical
"Encanto,"
followed by an unbelievable live
performance of
"We Don't Talk About Jada."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Well, remember 24 hours ago when
we thought Timothée Chalamet's
sternum was the craziest thing
we'd see all night?
That's right.
Will Smith walked onstage
during last night's
Academy Awards show
and slapped Chris rock
in the face.
And I got to say
the last thing I ever expected
to see at the Oscars was a
display of narcissism.
[ Laughter ]
We'll have more on this story
in a little bit,
but first let me
do the rest of the monologue,
which is kind of terrifying
now that I know
you can get slapped
for doing a bad joke.
[ Laughter ]
During his speech
on Saturday in Poland,
President Biden spoke directly
to the Russian people
and said that
President Vladimir Putin
was to blame for
Western economic sanctions.
'Cause if there's one thing
Biden loves,
it's pointing fingers.
[ Laughter ]
During a rally in Georgia
on Saturday,
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
attacked
transportation secretary
Pete Buttigieg and said, "He and
his husband can stay out
of our girls' bathrooms."
Well, I can't believe I'm going
to say this -- she's right.
[ Laughter ]
Men use the men's bathroom.
She got --
she got one right.
According to a new report,
Supreme Court justice
Clarence Thomas' wife Ginni
discussed ways to
overturn the 2020 election
with then White House
chief of staff Mark Meadows.
But don't worry,
she'll get her comeuppance
when she's eliminated first
on "dancing with the stars."
[ Laughter ]
Pepsi --
You guys, Pepsi has --
[ Laughter ]
Pepsi has announced a
partnership with
the restaurant chain IHOP to
offer a Pepsi maple syrup.
Great if you love Pepsi,
but you wish it took half an
hour to pour one.
[ Laughter ]